[Music]
christie's in charlotte north carolina
hi christy how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i have a
well two kids one's already in college
and my son is a high school junior he's
16 and started working and he saved
about five thousand dollars so far
his goal is to be debt-free
uh his college he doesn't wanna he wants
to have a debt-free degree
um right now he has three thousand
dollars in savings 800 in checking and
he had bought some stocks he invested
700 and um
then it went up to about 1500 it's down
about 1200 now and i called one of your
coaches earlier and asked he wanted to
know if he should invest part of that
savings for three thousand dollar
savings into a mutual fund and they said
no because he'll need the money and
follow he wants to go to community
college first and then to a state school
so he'll need the money in fall of 2025.
and
they said no don't invest into a mutual
fund i forgot to ask him about the
stocks whether he should keep well
they're more volatile than mutual funds
you know right
but he already had those he said not to
invest more of the savings into mutual
funds but we didn't
know what should he sell those i would
catch him
i'd cash it out and put it in savings
okay
trap your wins
and uh avoid the losses uh here and
there's two reasons for that
okay one is is that um
you know we're protecting the money that
he has made and it's not gonna go down
further
with geopolitical events in the air we
don't know exactly what the stock market
will do in the next six months it's not
a time to be screwing around with single
stocks the second thing that's more
important than that
because it's 700 or 1200 or whatever it
ends up being
is not going to cause him to be able to
go to school or keep him from going to
school
it doesn't answer it doesn't solve the
problem so if we lit it on fire it
doesn't end the him going to school
theory right
so right so what we really do with it
doesn't matter that much
but what does matter is what he believes
causes him to win
and if he starts to see himself as a
wonderful stock market day trader he's
setting himself up
for losses for the next three decades
before he figures out that's a dumb butt
idea
and so i don't want to
strengthen a muscle that i don't want
people using
yeah that was kind of his fun money that
was that was not his work money yeah i
know but i mean it's kind of like it's
kind of like let's say he dropped by the
casino and dropped a quarter in and it
came out 300 bucks
and but and then he did that again and
it worked again then he starts to think
that's where wealth comes from
yeah see we we let him buy those stocks
with the thought that it would probably
go down and he would learn his lesson
and then
it's brutal hey listen when i was his
age i would have taken that money and
bought laffy taffy so y'all are way
ahead of the game matter of fact you
might do that now i probably wouldn't so
i take most of my ramsey paycheck
um to the cafe and the dentist but but
yeah shift that man he's on the right
track just shift where he's aiming those
that financial that financial weaponry
and um something that's more sustainable
yeah
when you're teaching kids about money
and letting them participate in
different types of financial instruments
understand that you are that the actual
dollars that are moving around don't
matter much but what the the lesson that
you're teaching them is this is the way
to do it
and that's you know it's like well he'll
learn to be responsible if he has a
credit card no you want he'll learn to
use credit cards
you know that's don't give a teenager a
credit card dumber or rock because
you're gonna have an adult with a credit
card later